willkommen zurück zu „Understanding Quantum Information and Computation" – mein Name ist John Watrous und ich bin technischer Direktor für Bildung bei IBM Quantum
das ist die 13. Lektion der Reihe und die erste Lektion der vierten und letzten Einheit, die sich mit Quantum Error befasst
Correction – Quantum Computing hat das Potenzial, effiziente Lösungen für Rechenaufgaben zu ermöglichen, für die
keine effizienten klassischen Algorithmen bekannt sind und möglicherweise auch nicht existieren – es gibt jedoch sehr erhebliche Herausforderungen, die
überwunden werden müssen, wenn wir die Art von groß angelegten Quantum-Berechnungen implementieren wollen, von denen wir hoffen, dass sie eines Tages möglich sein werden
der Kern des Problems ist, dass Quantum-Information extrem fragil ist – man kann sie buchstäblich schon durch bloßes
Hinschauen zerstören – damit Quantencomputer korrekt funktionieren, müssen sie die in ihnen gespeicherte Quantum-Information
in extremem Maße von der sie umgebenden Umwelt isolieren – gleichzeitig muss der Quantencomputer selbst uns
sehr präzise Kontrolle über diese Quantum-Information bieten – dazu gehören eine ordnungsgemäße Initialisierung, genaue und zuverlässige
unitäre Operationen und natürlich die Möglichkeit, Messungen durchzuführen, damit wir die Ergebnisse der
Berechnung tatsächlich erhalten können – zwischen diesen Anforderungen besteht offensichtlich ein gewisses Spannungsverhältnis, und in den Anfängen des Quantum Computing gab es einige, die der Ansicht waren, dass die Fragilität
von Quantum-Information und ihre Anfälligkeit für Ungenauigkeiten sowie Umgebungsrauschen Quantum Computing letztendlich
unmöglich machen würde – heute besteht kaum ein Zweifel daran, dass der Bau eines genauen und zuverlässigen
groß angelegten Quantencomputers eine monumentale Herausforderung ist – aber wir haben ein entscheidendes Werkzeug, das uns dabei hilft und das die meisten
Fachleute auf diesem Gebiet optimistisch stimmt, dass groß angelegtes Quantum Computing eines Tages Realität werden wird – und dieses Werkzeug ist Quantum Error
Correction – in den nächsten vier Lektionen werden wir Quantum Error Correction mit Schwerpunkt auf den
Grundlagen besprechen – in dieser Lektion werfen wir einen ersten Blick auf Quantum Error Correction, einschließlich eines der allerersten Quantum-
Error-Correcting-Codes, die entdeckt wurden: dem 9-qubit-Shore-Code – außerdem werden wir ein weiteres grundlegendes Konzept in der Quantum-
Error Correction besprechen, das als Diskretisierung von Fehlern bekannt ist – in den folgenden Lektionen der Einheit werden wir ausgefeiltere und letztendlich bessere
Konstruktionen von Quantum-Error-Correcting-Codes kennenlernen und auch das Problem der Quantum-Berechnung auf kodierten Quantum-Informationen mit
Rechenkomponenten diskutieren, die selbst nicht perfekt sind und fehleranfällig sind – hier ist ein kurzer Überblick über die
Lektion – wir beginnen mit der Besprechung klassischer Repetitionscodes, die vielleicht die einfachste und grundlegendste Art
klassischer Error-Correcting-Codes sind – klassische Repetitionscodes sind nach klassischen Maßstäben der
Coding-Theorie keine besonders guten Codes – zumindest nicht für sich allein – aber das ist hier in Ordnung, denn wir setzen auf Einfachheit – insbesondere
werden wir uns den denkbar einfachsten klassischen Error-Correcting-Code ansehen, den wir dann als Grundlage für ein einfaches Beispiel verwenden werden
eines Quantum-Error-Correcting-Codes – dieses Beispiel ist der 9-qubit-Shore-Code, den wir ausführlich besprechen werden
– einschließlich einer Beschreibung des Codes selbst sowie der Verfahren zur Kodierung von qubits mit diesem Code, zur Fehlererkennung bei kodierten qubits und zur
Fehlerkorrektur – im dritten Teil der Lektion werden wir die Diskretisierung von Fehlern besprechen, die es uns ermöglicht, über beliebige Fehler bei
qubits nachzudenken, die prinzipiell ein Kontinuum von Möglichkeiten bilden, und sie in diskreten Begriffen auszudrücken – Fehler werden im Wesentlichen auf
sogenannte Bit-Flips und Phase-Flips reduziert – bevor wir uns mit den technischen Details der Quantum Error Correction befassen,
lohnt es sich, kurz über die Notwendigkeit von Quantum Error Correction sowie klassischer Error
Correction nachzudenken – wie ich zu Beginn der Lektion angedeutet habe, sind Quantencomputer aufgrund der
Fragilität von Quantum-Information besonders fehleranfällig – insbesondere können unerwünschte Wechselwirkungen mit der Umwelt oder mit anderen Worten
dem Rest der Welt Quantum-Information stören – diese unerwünschten Wechselwirkungen können Dekohärenz verursachen, bei der Information
im Wesentlichen in die Umwelt entweicht, was dazu führt, dass sich die im Quantencomputer gespeicherte Information immer mehr
klassisch verhält – es ist außerdem entscheidend wichtig, dass wir erkennen, dass Quantum-Operationen nur mit begrenzter
Genauigkeit durchgeführt werden können – wir möchten beispielsweise ein bestimmtes Quantum-gate auf einem qubit ausführen, aber weil physische Geräte
niemals perfekt sind, könnte das, was wir tatsächlich implementieren, nur eine Annäherung an dieses gate sein – das ist vielleicht kein großes Problem bei einem
einzelnen gate – aber wenn wir vorhaben, Tausende oder Millionen von Quantum-gates auszuführen, werden sich diese kleinen Ungenauigkeiten
anhäufen, und wenn die Berechnung abgeschlossen ist, könnten wir mit einem völlig anderen Zustand enden, als wir
erwartet haben – das ist also eine ganz andere Fehlerquelle, aber sie ist gewiss eine, die wir nicht
ignorieren können – Menschen beschäftigen sich seit fast einem Jahrhundert mit klassischen Error-Correcting-Codes, und diese Codes haben viele Anwendungen, unter anderem in der
Informationsübertragung und -speicherung – da klassische Rechenkomponenten jedoch so zuverlässig sind, brauchen wir tatsächlich
keine Error Correction, um klassische Computer zu bauen – es könnte nun sein, dass Error Correction tatsächlich auch nicht erforderlich ist,
um zuverlässige groß angelegte Quantencomputer zu bauen – zum Beispiel basiert die Grundidee des topologischen Quantum
Computings darauf, dass es möglich sein könnte, robuste Quantum-Systeme zu bauen, die aufgrund von
topologischen Eigenschaften der Systeme von Natur aus gegen Rauschen geschützt sind – aber wir wissen nicht, ob das möglich sein wird, und es wird ziemlich weitgehend geglaubt,
dass Error Correction für groß angelegtes Quantum Computing wahrscheinlich in irgendeiner Form unerlässlich sein wird – nun werden wir klassische
Repetitionscodes besprechen, die die Grundlage für unseren ersten Quantum-Error-Correcting-Code bilden: den 9-qubit-Shore-Code, den
wir gleich sehen werden – Repetitionscodes sind äußerst grundlegende Beispiele von Error-Correcting-Codes
– die Idee ist, dass wir bits gegen Fehler schützen können, indem wir jedes bit einfach mehrmals wiederholen – schauen wir uns insbesondere
den Drei-bit-Repetitionscode an – hier kodieren wir ein bit in drei, indem wir das bit einfach dreimal wiederholen – also wird
0 als 000 kodiert und 1 als 111 – wenn natürlich nichts schiefgeht, können wir
die beiden Möglichkeiten leicht unterscheiden – aber wenn ein Fehler aufgetreten ist und eines der bits umgekippt ist, sagen wir,
dass eine 0 zu einer 1 wird oder eine 1 zu einer 0 wird, dann können wir immer noch herausfinden, was das ursprüngliche bit war,
indem wir sehen, welcher der beiden binären Werte zweimal vorkommt – äquivalent dazu können wir dekodieren, indem wir den Mehrheitswert berechnen,
also den binären Wert, der am häufigsten vorkommt – und es ist nicht schwer zu erkennen, dass
bei höchstens einem Bit-Flip-Fehler die Dekodierung korrekt sein wird – wenn natürlich zwei bits umkippen oder
alle drei bits umkippen, dann wird es nicht funktionieren, und wir erhalten beim Dekodieren den falschen Wert – das ist eine allgemeine Eigenschaft,
die jeder Error-Correcting-Code besitzt – man kann möglicherweise einige Fehler korrigieren, aber nie jeden Fehler – letztendlich geht es darum,
die Fehlerwahrscheinlichkeit zu verringern, anstatt Korrektheit zu garantieren, was generell nicht
möglich ist – als Beispiel für eine Situation, in der wir die Fehlerwahrscheinlichkeit verringern können, nehmen wir an, dass unser
Ziel es ist, ein einzelnes bit an einen hypothetischen Empfänger zu übermitteln – dazu können wir bits durch einen
sogenannten binär-symmetrischen Kanal übertragen, der jedes durchgesendete bit unabhängig mit einer gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit
P umkippt – mit Wahrscheinlichkeit 1 minus P erhält der Empfänger also das bit, das wir senden wollten – aber mit Wahrscheinlichkeit P
wird das bit umgekippt und der Empfänger erhält den entgegengesetzten Wert zu dem, was wir gesendet haben – wenn wir also den Repetitionscode
nicht verwenden und stattdessen einfach das bit, das wir übermitteln wollen, direkt durch den Kanal senden, erhält der Empfänger das falsche bit mit
Wahrscheinlichkeit P – wenn wir hingegen das bit, das wir senden wollen, zuerst mit dem Drei-bit-Repetitionscode kodieren und
dann schick jede der drei Bits der Kodierung durch den Kanal, dann flippt jedes davon mit Wahrscheinlichkeit P, also
die Wahrscheinlichkeit eines Bit-Flips ist jetzt größer, weil es jetzt drei Bits gibt, die möglicherweise flippen können, statt einem
aber wenn höchstens eines der Bits flippt, kann der Empfänger es korrekt dekodieren – einen Fehler gibt es also erst nach
der Dekodierung, wenn zwei oder mehr Bits während der Übertragung flippen, und es ist nicht allzu schwer zu berechnen, dass dies mit
Wahrscheinlichkeit 3 * P ^2 - 2 * P Cub eintritt, für Werte von P kleiner als 1/12
das führt zu einer Verringerung der Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass der Empfänger das falsche Bit erhält – es wird in diesem Fall immer noch eine Fehlerchance geben, aber der
Code verringert die Wahrscheinlichkeit dafür, und wenn du die Chance noch weiter reduzieren wolltest, könntest du das mit einem
anderen Code tun, einschließlich aber nicht beschränkt auf die Möglichkeit, einen Wiederholungscode zu verwenden, bei dem das kodierte Bit wiederholt wird
mehr als dreimal – für Werte von P größer als 1/12 übrigens macht der Code tatsächlich
die Dinge schlechter in dem Sinne, dass er die Wahrscheinlichkeit erhöht, dass der Empfänger das falsche Bit bekommt – diesen Code würden wir also in dieser Situation
sicher nicht verwenden. Der Drei-Bit-Wiederholungscode ist ein klassischer fehlerkorrigierender Code, aber wir können auch betrachten, was passiert, wenn wir
versuchen, ihn zum Schutz von qubits vor Fehlern zu verwenden. Es ist kein besonders guter Quanten-Fehlerkorrekturcode, wie wir sehen werden – er
kann einige Fehler korrigieren, macht aber andere Fehler wahrscheinlicher. Er ist jedoch der erste Schritt hin zum Shore-
Code, also schauen wir uns an, wie er für qubits funktioniert. Zunächst zur Klarstellung: Wenn wir uns auf den 3-Bit-Wiederholungscode beziehen, der für
qubits verwendet wird, meinen wir eine Kodierung eines qubit wie auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt, wobei Alpha 0 plus beta 1
als Alpha 0000 0 plus beta 111 kodiert wird – mit anderen Worten, der Standardbasiszustand wird
dreimal wiederholt. Beachte insbesondere, dass das nicht dasselbe ist wie das dreimalige Wiederholen des Quantenzustands, wie bei einem gegebenen
Quantenzustand s, der als s tensor s tensor s kodiert wird – das ist eine Kodierung, die wir nicht in der Lage wären
für einen unbekannten Quantenzustand s umzusetzen, aufgrund des No-Cloning-Theorems. Die Kodierung, über die wir sprechen,
ist andererseits sehr einfach zu implementieren. Hier ist ein sehr einfacher Quantum circuit, der das mithilfe von zwei initialisierten Workspace-qubits und zwei
kontrollierten NOT-gates erledigt. Gehen wir nun davon aus, dass nach der Kodierung
ein Fehler auftritt – insbesondere, dass eine Pauli-X-Operation, also ein Bit-Flip, auf einem der
qubits stattfindet, und in dieser Abbildung ist es das mittlere qubit. Natürlich ist das nicht die einzige Art von Fehler, die auftreten kann, und du könntest
einwenden, dass ein Fehler die Form dieser perfekten unitären Operation annimmt – aber darauf kommen wir später in der Lektion zurück, und für jetzt können wir
es einfach als Beispiel betrachten. Hier ist der resultierende Zustand – er ist derselbe wie die ursprüngliche Kodierung, außer
dass das mittlere Bit innerhalb jedes K geflippt wurde. Das können wir offensichtlich aus den mathematischen Ausdrücken für den Zustand ablesen.
Aber angenommen, wir hätten nur die drei qubits und vermuteten, dass ein Bit-Flip stattgefunden haben könnte, wüssten aber nicht, welches qubit betroffen sein könnte –
eine Möglichkeit herauszufinden, ob ein Bit-Flip aufgetreten ist, wäre, eine Standardbasismessung durchzuführen und das Ergebnis zu untersuchen. In diesem Fall würden wir
entweder 0 eins 0 oder eins eins sehen – mit Wahrscheinlichkeiten abhängig von Alpha und beta – und in beiden Fällen wäre unser Schluss,
dass das mittlere Bit geflippt ist. Aber das ruiniert leider den ursprünglichen Quantenzustand, und dieser Zustand
könnte wertvoll für uns sein – schließlich geht es ja darum, diesen Quantenzustand zu schützen. Das ist also keine gute
Option. Was wir stattdessen tun können, ist den hier auf dem Bildschirm gezeigten Quantum circuit zu verwenden, bei dem wir den kodierten Zustand
in die oberen drei qubits einspeisen. Im Wesentlichen berechnet der circuit die Parität der Standardbasis-
zustände für die oberen zwei qubits sowie für die unteren zwei qubits der Kodierung – und das wird
den Ort des Bit-Flips aufdecken. Insbesondere erhalten wir in diesem Fall das Ergebnis eins für beide dieser Paritätsprüfungen, und aus
dieser Information können wir schließen, dass das mittlere Bit von den anderen beiden abweicht – das ist also offensichtlich dasjenige, das
geflippt ist. Und entscheidend dabei: Das führt nicht zum Kollaps des Zustands, sodass wir jetzt die Möglichkeit haben, diesen Bit-
Flip zu korrigieren, damit wir den ursprünglichen Zustand irgendwann möglicherweise dekodieren und zurückerhalten können. Auf die Korrektur
kommen wir gleich zurück, aber zuerst betrachten wir kurz die anderen Möglichkeiten für einen Bit-Flip-Fehler. Wenn stattdessen der Bit-Flip-Fehler
beim untersten oder linken qubit aufgetreten ist, würden wir das Ergebnis eins null erhalten – von unten nach oben gelesen – und wieder
würde sich der Zustand nicht ändern. Und wenn der Bit-Flip beim obersten qubit aufgetreten ist, wäre das Ergebnis
0 1 – und erneut ändert sich der Zustand nicht. Und übrigens: wenn es
überhaupt keinen Bit-Flip-Fehler gab, ist das Messergebnis 0 0, und erneut kommt der Zustand unverändert heraus.
Fassen wir das alles in Form einer Tabelle zusammen, in der wir jeden der möglichen Zustände auflisten, die wir bei höchstens einem Bit-Flip erhalten – das Messergebnis
nennen wir in diesem Zusammenhang das Syndrom der Fehlerkorrektur – sowie die Korrektur, die wir vornehmen müssen, um die ursprüngliche
Kodierung zurückzubekommen. Wenn kein Fehler aufgetreten ist, ist das Syndrom 0 0 und es muss nichts getan werden, um den
Zustand zu reparieren. Wenn das unterste oder linkeste qubit einen Bit-Flip erfahren hat, ist das Syndrom eins null, und die geeignete Korrektur
besteht darin, ein X-gate auf das unterste oder linkeste qubit anzuwenden. Die anderen beiden Fälle sind
ähnlich. Wenn wir also die entsprechende Korrektur basierend auf dem Syndrom anwenden, können wir sicher sein, die ursprüngliche
Kodierung in allen vier Fällen wiederherzustellen. Noch einmal: Wir betrachten nur die Möglichkeit, dass höchstens ein Bit-
Flip-Fehler aufgetreten ist. Das würde nicht korrekt funktionieren, wenn zwei oder drei Bits geflippt sind – und wir haben auch die
Möglichkeit anderer Fehler noch nicht berücksichtigt. Betrachten wir nun eine andere Art von Fehler im Quantenbereich: Bit-
Flip-Fehler sind nicht die einzigen Fehler, um die wir uns sorgen müssen. Zum Beispiel müssen wir uns auch um Phasen-Flip-
Fehler sorgen, kurz auch Phasen-Flips genannt, die durch Z-gates oder gleichwertig durch Pauli-Z-
Operationen beschrieben werden. Leider versagt der Drei-Bit-Wiederholungscode beim Erkennen von Phasen-Flips vollständig. Angenommen zum Beispiel, wir
kodieren ein qubit mit dem 3-Bit-Wiederholungscode wie zuvor, und ein Phasen-Flip-Fehler tritt am mittleren
qubit auf – wir erhalten dann den auf dem Bildschirm gezeigten Zustand, der genau die Kodierung ist, die wir erhalten hätten, wenn ein
Phasen-Flip am ursprünglichen qubit vor der Kodierung aufgetreten wäre. Wenn wir also denselben
circuit wie zuvor ausführen, um einen Fehler zu erkennen, würden wir das Syndrom 0 0 erhalten, was fälschlicherweise darauf hindeutet, dass keine Fehler aufgetreten
sind. Der 3-Bit-Wiederholungscode funktioniert also für höchstens einen Bit-Flip-Fehler, schlägt aber beim Erkennen von Phasen-Flip-Fehlern fehl.
Tatsächlich macht er die Dinge in gewissem Sinne sogar schlechter, denn jetzt haben wir dreimal so viele qubits, die möglicherweise Phasen-Flip-
Fehler erleben könnten. Wir haben festgestellt, dass der Drei-Bit-Wiederholungscode Phasen-Flip-Fehler völlig ignoriert – er scheint also
für den Umgang mit dieser Art von Fehler nicht sehr hilfreich zu sein. Aber wir können den Drei-Bit-Wiederholungscode tatsächlich so modifizieren, dass er
Phasen-Flip-Fehler erkennt, und ich erkläre jetzt, wie das gemacht werden kann. Hier ist der ursprüngliche circuit zum
Kodieren eines qubit mit dem 3-Bit-Wiederholungscode, und die Art, wie wir ihn modifizieren werden, ist sehr einfach: Wir wenden einfach ein
Hadamard gate auf jedes qubit der Kodierung an. Ein Hadamard gate transformiert einen Null-Zustand in einen Plus-Zustand und einen Eins-
Zustand in einen Minus-Zustand, sodass der Nettoeffekt darin besteht, dass wir den auf dem Bildschirm gezeigten Zustand erhalten, wobei ket
Plus-Plus-Plus und ket Minus-Minus-Minus eine Kurznotation für den Tensor von drei Plus-Zuständen bzw. drei Minus-
States ein Phasenflip-Fehler oder mit anderen Worten ein Z-gate verwandelt Plus-States in Minus-States und Minus-States in
Plus-States, sodass diese Kodierung nützlich ist, um Phasenflip-Fehler zu erkennen und zu korrigieren, und dazu können wir
den Fehlererkennungs-circuit von vorhin auf folgende Weise modifizieren: hier ist der circuit von vorhin, und was wir tun werden, ist
einfach, Hadamard gates sowohl am Anfang als auch am Ende einzufügen, wie es auf dem Bildschirm zu sehen ist
Die Idee ist ganz einfach: die ersten drei Hadamard gates wandeln Plus- und Minus-States zurück in Null- und Eins-States um,
dieselben Paritätsprüfungen wie zuvor finden statt, und dann bringt uns die zweite Schicht von Hadamard gates zurück zu unserer
Kodierung. Eine andere Denkweise ist, dass wir Phasenflip-Fehler im Grunde genommen in Bit-Flip-Fehler umwandeln, indem wir durch Hadamard-
Operationen konjugieren. Wir können den circuit übrigens noch ein kleines bisschen vereinfachen – dieser circuit hier ist vollständig äquivalent,
und du kannst das selbst überprüfen, wenn du möchtest. Wenn wir also unser Kodierungs-qubit in diesen circuit eingeben, unter der Annahme,
dass keine Phasenflip-Fehler aufgetreten sind, erhalten wir das Syndrom 0 0, was anzeigt, dass es keine Phasenflip-
Fehler gab. Und wenn wir tatsächlich einen Phasenflip-Fehler auf dem obersten qubit haben, dann flippen die ganz rechten Plusse und Minusse,
und das ergibt ein anderes Fehlersyndrom: 01. In diesem Fall wird damit der Ort des Phasenflips identifiziert, genau wie
wir es beim Bit-Flip hatten, und wir können es dann korrigieren, indem wir ein Z-gate auf das oberste qubit anwenden. Und die Situation
ist ähnlich für Phasenflip-Fehler auf einem der anderen beiden qubits, sodass wir tatsächlich erkennen und
bis zu einem Phasenflip-Fehler mit diesem Code korrigieren können. Leider können wir, wie du vielleicht vermutet hast, jetzt keine
Bit-Flip-Fehler mehr korrigieren. Alles ist jedoch nicht verloren, denn wir können diese beiden Codes tatsächlich kombinieren,
um einen Code zu erhalten, der sowohl Bit-Flip- als auch Phasenflip-Fehler korrigieren kann, und tatsächlich wird er in der Lage sein,
jeden Fehler auf einem einzelnen qubit zu korrigieren. Es ist jetzt an der Zeit, den 9-qubit-Shor-Code zu besprechen, der ein Quanten-
Fehlerkorrekturcode ist, den wir erhalten, indem wir die beiden Codes zusammenführen, die wir gerade gesehen haben, nämlich den Drei-Bit-
Wiederholungscode, der es uns ermöglicht, einen einzelnen Bit-Flip-Fehler zu korrigieren, und die modifizierte Version dieses Codes, die es uns ermöglicht, einen einzelnen Phasenflip-
Fehler zu korrigieren. Genauer gesagt ist der 9-qubit-Shor-Code der Code, den wir durch die Verkettung der beiden Codes erhalten, was bedeutet,
dass wir zunächst eine Kodierung anwenden, die ein qubit in drei kodiert, und dann die andere Kodierung auf jedes der
drei qubits separat anwenden, sodass wir insgesamt neun qubits erhalten. Wir können dies in der Form eines
circuit-Diagramms wie folgt ausdrücken: Zunächst wenden wir die modifizierte Version des 3-Bit-Wiederholungscodes an,
der Phasenflip-Fehler erkennt, und dann kodieren wir jedes der resultierenden qubits unabhängig mit dem ursprünglichen
3-Bit-Wiederholungscode. Wenn wir diesen circuit also ein wenig verkleinern, um etwas mehr Platz zu schaffen, können wir
den Code in etwas anderen Begriffen beschreiben, indem wir beschreiben, wie die beiden Standard-Basis-States für unser ursprüngliches qubit
kodiert werden, und sobald wir das wissen, können wir durch Linearität bestimmen, wie ein beliebiger qubit-Zustandsvektor
kodiert wird. Das ist also der 9-qubit-Shor-Code, und die Idee ist, dass einer der Codes es uns ermöglicht, Phasenflip-
Fehler zu korrigieren, und der andere Code es uns ermöglicht, Bit-Flip-Fehler zu korrigieren, und wie wir sehen werden, wird das tatsächlich bedeuten, dass wir
einen beliebigen Fehler auf einem einzelnen qubit korrigieren können. Schauen wir uns jetzt an, wie wir mit dem 9-qubit-
Shor-Code Fehler erkennen und korrigieren können, beginnend mit Bit-Flip-Fehlern, die auch X-Fehler genannt werden. Hier ist der circuit, der
die Kodierung durchführt, und nur damit es einfacher ist, darüber zu sprechen, werden wir die neun qubits, die wir aus diesem Code erhalten, als
in drei Blöcke aus je drei qubits gruppiert betrachten, wobei jeder Block die Kodierung darstellt, die wir durch Anwenden des
zweiten Kodierungsschritts erhalten, nämlich den gewöhnlichen 3-Bit-Wiederholungscode. Dieser wird in
diesem Zusammenhang als innerer Code bezeichnet, während der äußere Code der Code ist, der für den ersten Kodierungsschritt verwendet wird, der in diesem Fall die modifizierte
Version des Drei-Bit-Wiederholungscodes ist, der für Phasenflip-Fehler funktioniert. Um Bit-Flip-Fehler zu korrigieren, können wir
jeden der Blöcke einfach separat behandeln. Jeder Block ist eine Kodierung eines qubits mit dem Drei-Bit-Wiederholungs-
code, und dieser Code schützt vor Bit-Flip-Fehlern. Angenommen, zuerst tritt ein X-Fehler auf einem der qubits auf,
beispielsweise dem mittleren qubit im mittleren Block. Wenn wir jeden der Blöcke unabhängig auf Bit-Flip-Fehler prüfen und
alle gefundenen Fehler korrigieren, wird dieser Fehler korrigiert und die ursprüngliche Kodierung wird
wiederhergestellt. Tatsächlich könnten wir sogar mehrere X-Fehler haben und sie auf diese Weise immer noch korrigieren, vorausgesetzt, dass die Fehler
in separaten Blöcken liegen. Wenn wir zwei oder drei X-Fehler in einem einzigen Block hätten, wären wir in Schwierigkeiten, aber
solange es höchstens einen X-Fehler pro Block gibt, wird der innere Code sie erkennen und wir werden in der Lage sein, den ursprünglich kodierten
Zustand wiederherzustellen. Die Korrektur von Bit-Flip-Fehlern ist also für diesen Code eine ziemlich einfache Angelegenheit. Wir müssen auch Phasenflip-Fehler berücksichtigen,
oder mit anderen Worten Z-Fehler. Dieses Mal ist es nicht ganz so klar, was wir tun sollen, weil der äußere Code derjenige ist,
der Phasenflip-Fehler korrigiert, aber wir können sie nicht direkt erkennen und korrigieren, weil der innere Code irgendwie
im Weg ist. Aber wir werden gleich sehen, wie das geht. Um besser zu verstehen, wie X- und Z-
Fehler funktionieren und welche Auswirkungen sie innerhalb von Quanten-circuits haben, ist es hilfreich, einige einfache Beziehungen zwischen diesen Fehlern und C-
not-gates zu beobachten, und das wird auch in einer späteren Lektion hilfreich sein. Fangen wir zunächst mit X-Fehlern an.
oder X-gates und wie sie sich zu C-not-gates verhalten. Wenn wir ein X-gate auf das
Ziel-qubit eines C-nots anwenden und dann das C-not anwenden, ist das gleichwertig damit, die Reihenfolge zu tauschen und zuerst das C-not
durchzuführen. Andererseits, wenn wir ein X-gate auf das Steuer-qubit eines C-nots anwenden und dann das C-not anwenden, können wir die Reihenfolge nicht einfach
tauschen, sondern wir müssen stattdessen das X-gate auf beide qubits anwenden, und du kannst all diese Beziehungen
selbst überprüfen, wenn du möchtest, indem du nachdenkst, was mit Standard-Basis-States passiert. Die Situation ist ähnlich für Z-
Fehler, außer dass die Rollen des Steuer- und Ziel-qubits wechseln. Insbesondere, wenn wir ein
Z-gate auf das Steuer-qubit eines C-nots anwenden und dann das C-not durchführen, hat das den gleichen Effekt wie das Durchführen des
Z-gates nach dem C-not. Aber wenn wir das Z-gate stattdessen auf das Ziel-qubit anwenden, dann ist das
gleichwertig damit, zuerst das C-not durchzuführen und dann ein Z-gate auf beide qubits anzuwenden. Und schließlich sind all diese
Beziehungen symmetrisch in dem Sinne, dass wir immer die Reihenfolge der gates auf beiden Seiten jeder Gleichung tauschen können,
was gleichwertig ist damit, die Inverse oder die konjugierte Transponierte beider Seiten zu nehmen, da X-, Z- und C-not-
gates alle ihre eigenen Inversen sind. Schauen wir uns jetzt Phasenflip-Fehler an und wie wir sie
mit dem 9-qubit-Shor-Code erkennen und korrigieren können. Hier ist unser Kodierungs-circuit, und wir werden weiterhin die neun
qubits, die bei der Kodierung verwendet werden, als in drei Blöcke aus je drei qubits gruppiert betrachten. Angenommen, ein Z-Fehler tritt auf
einem der qubits auf, beispielsweise dem hier angezeigten. Mit dem, was wir gerade über Z-
gates und C-not-gates beobachtet haben, ist das gleichwertig mit zwei Z-Fehlern vor dem C-not, einem auf dem
Steuer-qubit und einem auf dem Ziel-qubit. Und diese Fehler vertauschen zufällig mit dem anderen C-not im Block, sodass wir
die Reihenfolge tauschen können, und hier ist das, was wir erhalten. Der untere Z-Fehler tut nichts, weil er auf einem Null-
State wirkt, und wir können alles andere verschieben und dieses Diagramm erhalten. Was wir also festgestellt haben, ist, dass ein Z-Fehler irgendwo innerhalb
der mittlere Block entspricht einem Z-Fehler, der auf dem mittleren qubit vor der zweiten Codierungsphase auftritt, und
du kannst genau dasselbe für einen Z-Fehler auf einem der qubits schlussfolgern – ein Phasenflip auf einem beliebigen qubit innerhalb eines Blocks
entspricht einem Phasenflip auf dem entsprechenden qubit vor der inneren Codierung, und das ist eigentlich ziemlich einfach und intuitiv, wenn du
darüber nachdenkst, wie Z-Fehler den Drei-Bit-Wiederholungscode beeinflussen. Eine Möglichkeit, mit einem Z-
Fehler umzugehen, besteht darin, den inneren Code zu dekodieren und dann Z-Fehler mit dem äußeren Code zu erkennen und zu korrigieren, was die modifizierte
Version des 3-Bit-Wiederholungscodes ist, der einen Z-Fehler korrigieren kann. Damit wird unser Z-Fehler korrigiert, und
wir könnten mit dem inneren Code erneut codieren, wenn wir das möchten. Wir können Z-Fehler auch
sozusagen direkt korrigieren, ohne zu dekodieren und dann erneut zu codieren. Das ist ziemlich einfach, aber um zu erklären, wie wir
das tun können, brauchen wir noch etwas mehr Platz. Angenommen, wir dekodieren den inneren Code
und berechnen dann das Syndrom für den äußeren Code mit derselben Methode wie zuvor, bei der wir nur die drei qubits des äußeren Codes einbeziehen, und
codieren dann erneut. Nun können wir all diese CNOT-gates etwas vereinfachen, und tatsächlich
können wir die Beziehungen zwischen NOT-gates und CNOT-gates, die wir gerade beobachtet haben, nutzen, um dabei zu helfen.
Auf diese Weise können wir vier CNOTs einsparen, und das ist der circuit, den wir erhalten. Wenn ein Z-Fehler auf einem der
qubits aufgetreten ist, teilt uns das Syndrom jetzt nicht mit, welches qubit einen Z-Fehler erfahren hat, sondern in welchem Block der Z-Fehler
aufgetreten ist. Aber das ist in Ordnung, denn wir wissen, dass es keine Rolle spielt, welches qubit innerhalb eines Blocks einen Z-Fehler erfährt. Die
Auswirkung ist für alle drei qubits innerhalb dieses Blocks gleich, und daher können wir den Z-Fehler tatsächlich korrigieren, indem wir ein Z-gate auf eines der
qubits innerhalb dieses Blocks anwenden. Dies ist übrigens ein Beispiel für das, was als Degeneriertheit in einem Fehler-
korrekturcode bezeichnet wird, bei dem wir einen bestimmten Fehler nicht eindeutig identifizieren, ihn aber trotzdem korrigieren können. Abschließend nehmen wir an, dass sowohl ein
Bitflip als auch ein Phasenflip-Fehler auftreten, möglicherweise auf demselben qubit. Angenommen zum Beispiel, dass ein
Bitflip und ein Phasenflip-Fehler auf genau diesem qubit hier auftreten. Wie sich herausstellt, können diese Fehler
vollständig unabhängig voneinander erkannt und korrigiert werden, und es spielt keine Rolle, ob wir jeden Block zuerst für einen
Bitflip und dann für Phasenflips korrigieren oder ob wir es andersherum machen. Um das zu verstehen, beobachten wir zunächst,
dass die Reihenfolge dieser Fehler keine Rolle spielt, sodass wir sie vertauschen können, wenn wir möchten. Der Grund dafür ist nicht, dass
X und Z kommutieren, denn das tun sie nicht – X mal Z ist gleich minus Z mal X – aber der
Faktor minus 1 hat in dieser Situation keine Auswirkung, da er eine globale Phase ist. Wir können den Z-Fehler jetzt genauso verschieben wie
zuvor, und an diesem Punkt ist es offensichtlich, dass wir, wenn wir zunächst jeden Block für X-Fehler korrigieren würden und dann für
Z-Fehler korrigierten, beide Fehler behoben hätten. Wenn wir aus irgendeinem Grund
beschlössen, zuerst Z-Fehler zu korrigieren, könnten wir das tun, und der X-Fehler hat dabei überhaupt keine Auswirkung.
Das muss wahr sein, weil erstens der X-Fehler mit jedem einzelnen gate im circuit kommutiert, der das
Syndrom für den äußeren Code berechnet, und zweitens die Reihenfolge zwischen dem X-Fehler und dem Z-gate, das wir zur
Korrektur anwenden, keine Rolle spielt, genau wie wir argumentiert haben, als das Z-gate ein Fehler war. Das ermöglicht die Korrektur des Z-
Fehlers, und wir können dann jeden Block korrigieren, um den X-Fehler zu beseitigen. Was wir also argumentiert haben, ist, dass wir
einen X-Fehler, einen Z-Fehler oder beides auf einem beliebigen der qubits mit diesem Code korrigieren können.
Tatsächlich können wir mehr Fehler als das korrigieren, beispielsweise mehrere X-Fehler, solange sie in verschiedene Blöcke fallen,
oder mehrere Z-Fehler, solange höchstens ein Block eine ungerade Anzahl davon erhält. Aber was zukünftig am relevantesten sein wird,
ist, dass wir einen X-Fehler, einen Z-Fehler oder beides auf einem beliebigen einzelnen qubit korrigieren können, und im letzten Teil der Lektion
werden wir sehen, warum das tatsächlich ausreicht, um zu schlussfolgern, dass dieser Code einen beliebigen Fehler auf einem beliebigen einzelnen
qubit korrigieren kann. Bevor wir zum letzten Teil der Lektion übergehen, in dem wir beliebige Quantenfehler betrachten, werden wir kurz
die Leistung des N-qubit-Shore-Codes untersuchen, wenn Fehler, die durch Pauli-Matrizen dargestellt werden, zufällig auf den
qubits auftreten. Um konkreter zu sein, betrachten wir ein einfaches Rauschmodell, bei dem Fehler unabhängig voneinander auf den qubits auftreten,
wobei jedes qubit mit Wahrscheinlichkeit p einen Fehler erfährt und keine Korrelation zwischen Fehlern auf verschiedenen
qubits besteht. Das schlimmste Szenario für den 9-qubit-Shore-Code ist, dass ein Y-Fehler, also sowohl ein X-Fehler als auch ein Z-
Fehler, auf jedem betroffenen qubit auftritt, und wir nehmen dieses schlimmste Szenario an, nur um eine Schranke zu erhalten.
für die Leistung des Codes. Du könntest aber auch in Betracht ziehen, dass zum Beispiel die drei Pauli-Fehler gleich
wahrscheinlich sind. Angenommen, Q ist ein qubit in einem bestimmten Zustand, den wir gegen Fehler schützen möchten, und stelle dir vor, dass
wir die Möglichkeit haben, den 9-qubit-Shore-Code zu verwenden. Sollten wir ihn verwenden? Nun, die Antwort ist nicht zwingend
ja, denn wenn es zu viel Rauschen gibt, also p zu groß ist, könnte die Verwendung des Shore-Codes die Dinge tatsächlich
verschlechtern, genau wie beim Wiederholungscode, wenn p größer als 1/2 ist. Aber wenn p klein genug ist, dann
lautet die Antwort ja, wir sollten den Code verwenden. Schauen wir uns also an, warum das so ist und was es bedeutet, dass p zu groß oder klein genug ist.
Für diesen Code kann der Shore-Code jeden Pauli-Fehler auf einem einzelnen qubit korrigieren, und im schlimmsten
Fall, in dem Pauli-Fehler Y-Fehler sind, bedeutet das, dass der Code Q mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit erfolgreich schützt, die durch den
auf dem Bildschirm gezeigten Ausdruck angegeben wird. Konkret funktioniert der Code, wenn keine Fehler auftreten, und das geschieht
mit Wahrscheinlichkeit 1 minus p hoch 9, da neun qubits vorhanden sind, die jeweils unbeeinträchtigt sein müssen. Und er funktioniert, wenn es genau
einen Fehler gibt. Da es neun verschiedene qubits gibt, die möglicherweise betroffen sein könnten, geschieht das mit Wahrscheinlichkeit 9 mal P mal (1 minus p) hoch 8.
Wenn wir andererseits den Code gar nicht erst verwenden würden, wäre unser einziges und einziges qubit von einem Fehler unbeeinträchtigt mit
Wahrscheinlichkeit 1 minus P. Der Code hilft also nur, wenn die erste Wahrscheinlichkeit größer als die zweite ist,
da diese Ausdrücke unsere Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeiten in den beiden Fällen darstellen: wenn wir den Code verwenden und wenn wir
ihn nicht verwenden. Hier ist ein Plot dieser beiden Funktionen für kleine Werte von p, und wir stellen fest, dass der Break-Even-Punkt bei
etwa 3 und drei Vierteln Prozent liegt. Wenn p also kleiner als dieser Wert ist, dann hilft der Code.
Am Break-Even-Punkt sind die Wahrscheinlichkeiten gleich, also verschwenden wir nur unsere Zeit zusammen mit 8 qubits, wenn
wir den Code verwenden – aber ansonsten schadet es nicht. Und jenseits dieses Punktes sollten wir diesen Code absolut nicht verwenden,
da er die Fehlerwahrscheinlichkeit auf dem codierten qubit tatsächlich erhöht, was wir in diesem Zusammenhang typischerweise als das
logische qubit bezeichnen. Und das geschieht einfach deshalb, weil die Wahrscheinlichkeit von zwei oder mehr Fehlern auf neun qubits
größer ist als die Wahrscheinlichkeit eines Fehlers auf einem einzelnen qubit für Werte von p in diesem Bereich. 3 und drei Viertel Prozent erscheinen vielleicht nicht sehr
gut, insbesondere im Vergleich zu 50%, was der analoge Break-Even-Punkt für den Drei-Bit-Wiederholungscode für
klassische Informationen ist. Aber es ist schwieriger, Quanteninformationen zu schützen, und obwohl dieser
Code eine brillante Entdeckung als allererster Quantenfehlerkorrekturcode darstellt und sich hervorragend für pädagogische Zwecke eignet, ist die
Tatsache, dass er in praktischer Hinsicht einfach kein besonders guter Code ist. Bisher haben wir X-Fehler betrachtet
und Z-Fehler im Kontext des 9-qubit-Shore-Codes. Betrachten wir nun beliebige Fehler.
Beginnen wir zunächst mit unitären Fehlern. So könnte ein solcher Fehler zum Beispiel einer sehr kleinen
Rotation der Blochsphäre entsprechen, was möglicherweise einen Fehler darstellt, der durch ein nicht perfektes gate entsteht,
oder es könnte eine beliebige andere unitäre Operation auf einem qubit sein, nicht notwendigerweise etwas nahe der Identität.
Es mag so erscheinen, als wäre die Korrektur solcher Fehler schwierig – es gibt unendlich viele mögliche Fehler wie
diesen, und es ist unvorstellbar, dass wir irgendwie genau identifizieren könnten, welcher Fehler es ist, und ihn dann rückgängig machen. Aber wir
müssen eigentlich nichts anderes tun als das, was wir bereits besprochen haben. Solange wir einen Bit-Flip, einen Phasen-Flip oder beides korrigieren können, werden wir
tatsächlich erfolgreich einen beliebigen unitären Einzelqubit-Fehler korrigieren. Ich erkläre jetzt, warum das
so ist. Zunächst können wir, wie alle 2×2-Matrizen, eine beliebige unitäre Matrix
die einen Fehler auf einem einzelnen qubit darstellt, als Linearkombination der vier Pauli-Matrizen einschließlich der Identität ausdrücken.
Übrigens, wie du vielleicht bemerkt hast, verwende ich die Großbuchstaben X, Y und Z, um die Nicht-Identitäts-Pauli-Matrizen zu bezeichnen.
Das werde ich für den Rest dieser Serie so beibehalten. Das ist konventionell in der Quanten-Fehlerkorrektur und macht
die Dinge in diesem Kontext auch etwas leichter lesbar. Es wird außerdem praktisch sein, Indizes zu verwenden, um anzugeben, auf welches
qubit eine bestimmte qubit-unitäre Operation wirkt. Wenn wir zum Beispiel Qiskit's
qubit-Nummerierungskonvention verwenden, die bei qubit Null auf der rechten Seite beginnt, dann haben wir die auf dem Bildschirm gezeigten Ausdrücke für
verschiedene unitäre Operationen auf einzelnen qubits, wobei in jedem Fall die unitäre Matrix mit der Identitätsmatrix
auf jedem anderen qubit tensoriert wird. Insbesondere können wir UK – also U angewendet auf qubit K – als dieselbe
Linearkombination wie zuvor ausdrücken, wobei jede Pauli-Matrix auf qubit K angewendet wird. Den Index für die Identität brauchen wir
übrigens nicht anzugeben. Das Verständnis hierbei ist, dass dies die Identität auf allen
qubits ist. Angenommen nun, dass |ψ⟩ die 9-qubit-Kodierung eines qubit-Zustands ist. Wenn der Fehler U zufällig auf
qubit K auftritt, erhalten wir UK mal |ψ⟩, was wir als Linearkombination von Pauli-Operationen ausdrücken können, die auf |ψ⟩ wirken –
was im Fall der Identität natürlich einfach |ψ⟩ ist. An diesem Punkt ist es hilfreich zu beobachten, dass die Pauli-Y-
Matrix gleich i mal X mal Z ist, sodass wir diese Substitution in unserem
Ausdruck vornehmen können. Dieser Fehler ist also aufgetreten, und jetzt versuchen wir, ihn mit demselben Verfahren zu korrigieren wie
zuvor. Der erste Schritt ist die Berechnung des Syndroms, das im Fall des Shor-Codes 8 Bits lang ist – zwei Bits für jedes der
dreimal, dass wir den inneren Code verwenden, sowie zwei zusätzliche Bits für den äußeren Code. Aber das spielt keine große Rolle; wir können es einfach als
eine Zeichenkette fester Länge betrachten. Hier ist eine Beschreibung des Zustands, den wir kurz vor der Messung des Syndroms erhalten, wobei jedes
Syndrom die acht Bits ist, die wir vom entsprechenden Pauli-Fehler erhalten. Beachte an diesem Punkt, dass die beiden
Systeme im Allgemeinen korreliert sind – und das ist wirklich der Schlüssel, damit das alles funktioniert. Durch die Messung des Syndroms
kollabieren wir den Zustand effektiv auf einen, bei dem eine der vier Pauli-Operationen auf das
K-te qubit von |ψ⟩ angewendet wurde, und wir wissen anhand des Syndroms, welche Pauli-Operation es war, sodass wir sie korrigieren können,
falls nötig. Insbesondere, wenn wir das Syndrom messen und die entsprechende Korrektur vornehmen, erhalten wir einen Zustand der
Form, die auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wird – entscheidend ist, dass dies ein Produktzustand ist. Wir haben unsere ursprüngliche unkorrupte Kodierung als
rechten Tensorfaktor, was hier am wichtigsten ist, und auf der linken Seite haben wir eine Dichtematrix σ, die
ein zufälliges Fehlersyndrom beschreibt. Es gibt jedoch keine Korrelation mehr mit dem System, das uns interessiert –
nämlich dem auf der rechten Seite –, da die Fehler korrigiert wurden. Zu diesem Zeitpunkt können wir die Syndrom-qubits verwerfen oder zurücksetzen,
falls wir sie erneut verwenden möchten. Das ist eigentlich sehr wichtig, denn so wird die Zufälligkeit oder Entropie,
die durch Fehler erzeugt wird, aus dem System entfernt. Und so funktioniert die Diskretisierung von Fehlern – zumindest für unitäre
Fehler. Im Wesentlichen projizieren wir durch die Syndrom-Messung den Fehler effektiv auf einen Fehler, der durch
eine Pauli-Matrix beschrieben wird. Auf den ersten Blick mag es zu schön erscheinen, dass wir beliebige unitäre Fehler
so korrigieren können – selbst Fehler, die winzig und für sich allein kaum wahrnehmbar sind. Aber was hier wichtig zu erkennen ist:
Dieser Fehler ist eine unitäre Operation auf einem einzelnen qubit, und durch das Design des Codes kann eine Einzelqubit-Operation den
Zustand des logischen qubit, das kodiert wird, nicht verändern. Alles, was sie bewirken kann, ist, den Zustand aus dem Raum gültiger
Kodierungen herauszubewegen – aber dann bringen ihn die Korrekturen genau dahin zurück, wo er war. Betrachten wir abschließend, was passiert,
wenn ein beliebiger, nicht notwendigerweise unitärer Fehler auftritt. Das Setup ist dasselbe wie zuvor:
Wir haben ein qubit mit dem Shor-Code in 9 kodiert, und ein beliebiger Fehler, dargestellt durch einen qubit-Kanal Φ,
tritt auf einem der qubits auf. Wie wir sehen werden, wird alles auf nahezu dieselbe Weise funktionieren
wie bei unitären Fehlern. Der erste Schritt zur Überprüfung dessen ist die Betrachtung einer Kraus-Darstellung unseres
Fehlers. Was wir nun tun können, ist genau dieselbe Überlegung wie bei unitären Fehlern anzuwenden – außer dass wir das
auf die Kraus-Matrizen anwenden, anstatt auf eine einzelne unitäre Matrix, die einen Fehler darstellt.
Insbesondere kann jede Kraus-Matrix als Linearkombination von Pauli-Matrizen ausgedrückt werden, was uns ermöglicht,
die Wirkung dieses Fehlers Φ auf welches qubit K auch immer in der Form auszudrücken, die hier auf dem
Bildschirm gezeigt wird. Alles, was wir hier wirklich tun, ist, die Kraus-Matrizen als Linearkombinationen von Pauli-
Matrizen zu entwickeln. Wenn wir dann das Fehlersyndrom berechnen und messen und alle aufgedeckten Fehler korrigieren, erhalten wir einen
ähnlichen Zustand wie im Fall eines unitären Fehlers. Ich werde die Details nicht durchgehen – alles ist dem unitären
Fall sehr ähnlich und auch etwas unübersichtlicher aufzuschreiben, aber konzeptionell ist es ziemlich
unkompliziert. Ich sollte erwähnen, dass sich all das auf andere Quanten-Fehlerkorrekturcodes verallgemeinern lässt, einschließlich Codes, die Fehler auf mehreren
qubits korrigieren können. In einem solchen Fall können Fehler auf mehreren qubits als Linearkombinationen von Tensorprodukten von Pauli-
Matrizen ausgedrückt werden, und entsprechend beschreiben die verschiedenen möglichen Syndrome Korrekturen, die auf mehreren qubits durchgeführt werden, anstatt nur auf einem.
Aber die zugrunde liegende Idee ist genau dieselbe: Durch die Messung des Syndroms
projizieren oder kollabieren wir Fehler effektiv auf eine diskrete Menge von Möglichkeiten, die durch Tensorprodukte
von Pauli-Matrizen dargestellt werden, und durch die Korrektur dieser Fehler – also der Pauli-Fehler – können wir den ursprünglichen
kodierten Zustand wiederherstellen. Gleichzeitig wird die dabei erzeugte Zufälligkeit in die Syndrom-qubits verschoben, die wir dann
verwerfen oder zurücksetzen können – was entscheidend ist, da so die durch Fehler und Syndrom-Messungen erzeugte Entropie
aus dem System entfernt wird. Und das ist das Ende der Lektion, in der wir einen ersten Blick auf
die Quanten-Fehlerkorrektur geworfen haben, einschließlich des 9-qubit-Shore-Codes und der Diskretisierung von Fehlern. Ich hoffe, du wirst mich bei der
nächsten Lektion begleiten, in der wir den Stabilisator-Formalismus besprechen, der uns ein mächtiges Werkzeug zum Beschreiben und
Analysieren einer großen und interessanten Klasse von Quanten-Fehlerkorrekturcodes bietet, einschließlich solcher, die vielversprechende Kandidaten für
echte Quantencomputer sind. Auf Wiedersehen bis dahin.